what do I keep with me every night in  bed a your husband  a packet of biscuits in case I get  hungry  B air pods because my own snoring wakes  me up okay or see a stuffed toy animal  called bunny bunny yeah yeah  when did you get bunny the day I was  born  bunny is very old it doesn't look  anything like it doesn't doesn't  remotely resemble a bunny rabbit anymore  she's so old but  have my koala as well oh you do oh good  do you sleep with it every night though  every night so okay and my husband this  because he's like this is so weird that  we have to be in bed number he waits  until he thinks I'm asleep and then he  throws bunny out of bed no yeah and I  get so mad I'm like everybody out of bed  oh the things bunny has seen yeah well  no I shouldn't see that anyways no no  sorry